every spring in Rover every spring in
roll it's hard to say every spring in
rural Vermont the sound of SAP dripping
into galvanized metal bucket signal the
beginning of the traditional season for
gathering maple syrup or maybe we have
no error so what's what's what's the
real subject here every spring in row I
can't say that every spring in rural
Vermont the sound of SAP dripping into
galvanized metal buckets so this is a
subject hear the sound of SAP dripping
into galvanized metal buckets now is
that singular pearl we're talking about
the sound we're talking about a sand the
sound you we're not talking about the
sounds so this right over here this
right over here is a singular singular
subject now what do they do with the
verb well the verb right over here they
have the plural form of the verb signal
if we had the sounds we could say the
sounds signal the beginning of the
traditional season but we have only we
only have one sound we have the sound
the sound we need its singular subject
we'd a singular verb so we need signals
right over here so the error is in Part
C